welcome back to new rock stars I'm Erik
Voss and the Marvel Cinematic Universe
is on the precipice of a huge
announcement that Marvel fans need to
keep us from plunging into despair as if
we were in a flightless armored suit for
this Comic Con at home will be a virtual
event taking the place of the live
convention in San Diego every year it's
gonna go down July 22nd through 26th in
which all of us not just the sweaty
huddled masses of hall each will learn
together what's in store for the future
of marble and other fandoms the light
hopefully at the end of the tunnel
yeah I'm doing it I'm giving you hope
don't give me we are starting to get
reports about those announcements so
let's preview everything we know about
the updated Marvel timeline coming our
way at Comic Con in a few weeks and this
year's big surprise reveal about an
upcoming title beyond the listed ones
let's start with Black Widow
Marvel's next biggest title and
according to some sources Marvel has two
black widow trailers in the pipeline
with the British Board of Film
classification approving two cuts for
media release 1 2 minutes and 38 seconds
another one minute 44 seconds another
source claimed to have already seen this
trailer describing the film's release
state updated to November 6 2020 in new
unseen footage of David Harbor as red
guardian Alexei Shuster Cove last March
Disney Marvel released what they called
their final trailer for Black Widow so
I'm guessing the studio has teased about
as much as they wanted teased ahead of
this film but a greater focus on harbor
to me sounds like an attempt to tie in
with some anticipated increase in
pervert news with updates about stranger
things season 4 in the months ahead
essentially we're entering Black Widow
page of harbor the Black Widow director
also just confirmed that the film will
straight-up pass the baton from Scarlett
Johansson to Florence Pugh and propel
another female storyline now in the past
I proposed the bat batshit theory that
lose from that black widow trailers
suggests a possible surgical face swap
between etosha and Elena so that the
natasha we've known all this time could
still live on just with Florence pues
face they say not that bad [ __ ] because
it totally happens in the comics we'll
get more into this in this week's
episode of rogue theory but what about
Disney
Plus well the streaming service has
announced three panels as of this taping
documentary series Marvel 6-1-6 Phineas
and Ferb and the right stuff but I'm
thinking there's also gotta be a panel
for the Falcon the Winter Soldier the
six episodes on Disney plus we're
tentatively scheduled for all 2020 but
of course production suspended and it is
reported to resume in August but at the
very least we can hope for more footage
beyond those brief shots we saw in the
Super Bowl spot earlier this year and a
firmer release date same goes for one
division which is still tentatively
scheduled for December 2020 and is
reported to be about nine episodes in
length with Evan Peters joining the cast
of mystery roll now the Eternals was
rescheduled to February 12 2021 and four
months sources have claimed a trailer
for the film is in the can ready to
release whenever the studio is ready to
announce shang-chi is a bit further
behind production but and star the film
teased that the cast and crew did shoot
some awesome footage that he'd love to
show at Comic Con I kind of hope that
Comic Con doesn't get cancelled because
I know which I can't say I hope that we
get to go to Comic Con because I think
we would have some pretty awesome one
unconfirmed screengrab going around
listening media links for a Marvel comic
con panel though I don't know who would
format it like it was written on a
typewriter with that spacing and
describe anything as to concept arts
hopefully we'll also get more details
about Bay's for titles beyond these like
more than three seconds of Loki whether
Peter Parker will face Kraven Norman
Osborn the sinister six or all of them
in his third film delayed to November
2021 do you tell us about four or four
more four in February 2022 how Sam Raimi
will hopefully connect back to zones
five diverse and Doctor Strange the
multiverse of madness March twenty
twenty two black panther in May 20-22
Captain Marvel - coming in July 2020 to
bleed how lewis will recap in game an
alien 3 yeah miss Marvel moonlight and
she-hulk that's all of that appreciated
we'll just be more on the titles that
have already been announced that's not
what Hall H is about these panels are
for making big aspirational fanservice
II promises that like the Inhumans movie
they'd never be delivered on so how is
Feige gonna swing for the fences in 2020
what big old marshal Ali as blade-style
bombshell is he sitting on to reassure
the fans or Disney shareholders that the
best is yet to come wait just because he
won't be sweating it out at comic-con
doesn't mean it still isn't summertime
and your family jewels aren't sweating
it out in your shorts sauna well have no
fear my bushy buddies our friends at
manscaped are here with the great
products to keep you looking good and
feeling good in this hot summer weather
to keep your little piggies looking good
in flip-flops they've got the new
manscape sheers 2.0 nail kit the perfect
add-on to your bathroom grooming regimen
the sheers 2.0 is a newly improved
luxury 4-piece nail kit including
tweezers Clippers scissors in the nail
file I'm not saying you should use these
tools that break out of prison he
shouldn't looking great but I am saying
that the tempered stainless steel is
probably strong enough to do it they're
a perfect package 3.0 kit comes with the
essential lawn mower 3.0 water resistant
cordless body trimmer and a ton of other
liquid foundations to round out your
manscaping routine one of those
formulations is a manscaped cropped
preserver an anti chafing ball deodorant
and moisturizer the outside might be
heat miser but the manscape crop
preserver keeps your man-bag feeling
frosty subscribe to the perfect package
with a peak hygiene plan today and get a
new blade refill for your lawn mower
trimmer delivered to your door every
three months totally hassle-free and for
a limited time subscribers get not one
but two free gifts the shed travel bag
and the patented high performance
reduced chafing manscaped boxer briefs
these boxer briefs do not count a swim
trunks at your friend's pool party trust
me I have tried get 20% off and free
shipping to the US UK Canada and
Australia when you use the promo code
stars 20 and manscaped com that's code
stars 20 for 20 percent off at manscape
comm see our link in the video's
description okay the biggest
headline-making revealed that Kevin
Feige could announce at comic-con at
home would be a long anticipated Marvel
film title like a rebooted MCU fantastic
for the holiday 2022 window is wide open
at the moment now that could go to
guardians of the galaxy vol 3 but
Marvel's hands are kind of tied with
James Gunn's schedule with the Suicide
Squad for one
Brothers which is still set to release
August 6 2021 I'm not sure if that would
give Gunn enough time to get guardians
vol 3 shot wrapped and post by the end
of 2022 and further production delays
good ship things back even further for
gun and the rest of the huge Guardians
cast all of which are essential to that
story so yeah the cast of an MCU
fantastic for joining the chat at Comic
Con at home would be Marvel's biggest
game-changer in years especially if that
read Richard Square got filled in by
John Krasinski but Marvel might be
working toward another team he's like
the Thunderbolts the return of Zemo and
Falcon Winter Soldier Thunderbolt Ross
and Black Widow and emphasis on
alternate Avengers figures like red
Guardian could all be pointing to the
development of a new Avengers B Squad
also various upcoming Marvel titles
could be pointed to the possible set up
of The Young Avengers with Billy Kaplan
Wiccan and Tommy Shepherd speed and Wan
Division stature Cassie Lang and ant-man
3 Kate Bishop and Hawkeye series and
maybe Elijah Bradley Patriot and the
Falcon Winter Soldier or Nate Richards
iron lad aka King and Loki first a few
teams that could be linked with dr.
strange like Marvel's Illuminati finally
that would join Strange with the likes
of Namor Reed Richards Professor X there
was that Easter Egg on Tony Stark's
phone when as far back in Iron Man 2 or
even the midnight Suns which could tie
Strange with blade Ghost Rider maybe
even moon night Mikey could simply
announce a crossover event that will
link several of these properties like
The Secret Invasion which seems to be
the case with all the scrolls all over
the place Whedon Secret Wars there's
also some rumors that Feige will pull a
similar casting announcement as he did
with marshal Ali as blade it really just
requires an actor to walk out wearing a
hat this could mean an actor is a big
bad for phase 4 or 5 like Galactus or
Victor Von Doom Kang the Conqueror
Mephisto magneto or maybe we'll get a
confirmation that one of these a listers
rumored to be in talks for Marvel roles
like Keanu Reeves says silver surfer
Henry Cavill is Wolverine really a win
right for the pickin would be Ryan
Reynolds in an MCU debut for Deadpool
the guy is already thirstily crashing
the streaming calls of the x-men cast
just give this guy the zoom like Feige
and yeah our upcoming episode of rogue
theory will also speculate wildly on
what dream announcement we want to see
at Comic Con at home be sure to check it
out and comment down below with what you
hope to be announced for Marvel's future
and for more theory discussion join our
official discord server by becoming a
patreon at patreon.com slash new
rockstars follow me on the instagram @
EA vas following new rockstars and
subscribe for breakdowns of everything
you love thanks for watching
[Music]